[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to Siskel
and Ebert arguably the most famous
critics who ever lived even years after
their deaths people still remember their
reviews their personalities even their
thumbs in my opinion a good critic
should do two things offer a unique and
interesting point of view and do so in a
passionate and entertaining way
well the points of view were indeed
great it's the entertainment part that
kept us coming back
despite their quote professional
relationship Siskel and Ebert acted like
emotional children more times than can
be counted and we'll also take a look at
a new film about a friendship between a
boy and a whale sort of reminds me of
our relationship damn they'd argue about
whose name would be first in the show's
title they constantly mocked each
other's physical appearances they
figured about who would sit closest to
the desk on a talk-show to the point
where the host had to sit in between
them to shut them off even when doing
the promos they couldn't stop pissing
each other off that's this week on
Siskel and Ebert and the movie and the
assholey and that's Roger and when it
came to the movies they reviewed they
were just as entertaining the two of
them had an undying love of cinema that
United them whenever they were on screen
whether they liked the film hated it or
disagreed on it there was an absolute
passion for it every time
surprisingly two big personalities with
a lot of big thoughts resulted in a lot
of big waves it was wonderful to see
them get so into it whether they were
angry at a film or each other you
couldn't help but appreciate how much
they loved talking about it but at the
same time giggle at just how angry they
got now of course critics like myself
never lose my temper
oh crap still fun to celebrate how
invested they were especially during the
funny parts so today I'm gonna count
down the funniest arguments funniest
rants and even funniest laughs these two
made in a long career of film reviewing
now keep in mind I'm not including
reviews
roper or other critics don't get me
wrong they were very passionate and
entertaining too but Roger Ebert and
chin Siskel truly had a connection that
was one-of-a-kind and couldn't be
duplicated and that's what I'm here to
focus on and celebrate so get ready for
their top 11 funniest moments why table
11 because I'd like to go one step
beyond so sit back and enjoy the top 11
funniest Siskel and Ebert review
[Music]
numberless babies day out is a different
kind of movie it all surprising to me
and let's just say it everyone in
existence Cisco really liked babies day
out
apparently it reminded him of all the
comedic silent films it almost plays
like an old-fashioned silent film the
old-fashioned look kept me involved as
much as anything and I have a suspicion
that little kids will really eat up this
fantasy of the baby getting in trouble
but not getting in trouble
to nobody's surprise Eber thought Cisco
was nuts this movie is not funny it's
way too long the burglars who are
recycled right out of home alone are
really awkwardly ridden on some of the
arguments as to why almost seemed as
strange as Cisco's recommendation I
hated this movie more than any other
movie on this show and I'm I'm really
surprised at you you should be ashamed
of yourself kind of an odd start to a
baby's day out argument I think a little
child sees this baby about to fall off
of tall buildings and be crushed by big
cars isn't gonna know it's funny I guess
it's not funny but I've yet to see
social media attack and don't go after
anything
sure enough instead of talking about the
film being a dumb flag they give them to
what cinematic elements might scarred
children from watching baby stay out as
well as what cinematic elements
apparently scarred Roger when he was
younger three and a half years old I
went to see a movie where Mickey Rooney
was standing on a Ledge outside a window
it was a comedy everybody was laughing I
was terrified as far as I'm concerned
mr. Bean's Holiday is a thriller you
might as well take your kids to see
Halloween after gene makes the threat
that sensitive children could grow up to
be like Roger Ebert they even argue
about which theatre each of them saw it
at man they could bitch about anything I
better go back and find out who attended
that sneak preview I saw all those
children are in dear jeopardy of
becoming we attended the same screening
and those kids were not with that movie
he didn't attend it I saw it in Michigan
City Indiana last Saturday so you was a
totally different audience Touche it's a
strange and awkward bit of comedy but I
guess that figures when you're reviewing
a strange and awkward bit of comedy I'm
really surprised that you should be
ashamed of yourself what first of all
they're not agreeing with you
never unashamed of that I've been proud
of that number 10 the new movie Alaska
which is in the old tradition of
real-life nature adventures this time
it's jeans turn to ask what the hell
were you thinking when Roger gives a
positive review to a children's
adventure named Alaska about two kids
climbing mountains to save their dad on
its own level I enjoyed it I imagine
it's targeted at kids up to about 13 and
I think a lot of them are gonna love it
since there are the kids were babies
Roger thought it was delightful but she
goes right for the offense you know how
you always say to me you missed the boat
on this one whenever you missed the
harbor this is I think one of those
laughably bad pictures I've seen in a
long time gets in some weird reasons why
the word father and this is a movie not
other research the cult the father word
father has never mentioned for 40
minutes in this picture what they're not
talking or acting remotely like remotely
like kids who's lost their father trying
to find did you know Freddie never says
the word human on his search for killing
humans will be ruined they almost
immediately jump into yelling at each
other oh I do hate it when mom and dad
fight your criticism on this movie is
utterly irrelevant to the experience of
the film on the screen runner it would
be mindless to anyone seeing the film
wasn't meaningless to me after bringing
up the legit criticism about how silly
it is nobody can find that plane which
has someone who reviewed that film I can
vouch for that they start talking over
each other like it's a political debate
smooth Rogers to you when you describe
when you nominee feminine major
strengthened and the ten-year-old kids
are gonna be saying gee they didn't
finally it ends with the ultimate test
of Roger proving he likes this movie he
wants to the camera and says he likes
this movie I just want you to say that
you really enjoyed it I did enjoy this
movie I enjoyed this movie I'm sure a
lot of people felt this movie didn't
give them much but it did at least give
them a pretty funny review incredible
how can you say that
[Music]
number nine
our next film is called frozen assets
and we take a step way down in quality
here this is one of the dumbest comedies
I have ever seen you're going very easy
on it I said so far I guess you have to
include what they at the time to clear
the worst comedy they've ever seen
presumably similar to you I've never
even heard of this movie but hearing
both of them take sucker punches and it
is really a lot of fun it was as
depressing and experiences I've ever had
going in movies that's 23 years of going
to the movies professionally maybe six
seven thousand pictures well gene I was
going to the movies professionally for
two or three years and there was nothing
I saw during that time that even
approached this and it's abysmal
awfulness that you and some of the jokes
from the film about a dude who thinks
he's managing a bank but really it's a
sperm bank quickly shows where they're
coming from you know what you can't take
it that way the movie would don't be shy
my door is open
if you need a hand to hands hey I'll get
down on all fours that's how eager I am
to please it's pretty standard until the
two of them actually start to laugh at
the fact that they probably saw the
worst comedy ever made but then realize
they don't even want to give it that
recognition because then people might
want to see it this is perhaps the worst
comedy ever made remake that the set
makes it sound good they get the second
worst comedy ever made they won't use it
the movie is so bad that they start
discussing what rewards they'll be given
in the next life as Karma for having to
sit through a review you know the theory
of reincarnation where the dues we pay
in this life die and we may get to
collect in another lifetime for having
seen this movie I want months and months
and months in a beautiful valley with
honey and nectar and zephyr like breezes
you know you have simple tastes I
couldn't we had a big car this is a heck
we hip-hop amusing when a film is so bad
you spend most of the review fantasizing
yourself dead and in another life where
things apparently make more sense not
even the worst comedy ever made just the
worst movie ever made I don't know sperm
banks karma and Anouk I know what you'd
expect in a normal review
that's part of what makes them so much
fun to watch get something valuable
Zephyr like breezy number eight my next
movie is not only the first feature in a
long time
starring televisions top star Bill Cosby
but it is also one of the worst movies
of the year
no both is one of the biggest bombs ever
made and one of the worst movies ever
made and I'm sure this were the
controversies about this don't stop
Leonard part six got a lot of hate at
the time any birds dry delivery of how
awful the film is even has chained in
stitches you can actually hear of
snickering off-camera frogs squirrels
and rainbow trout Cosby knows he's in
trouble with hitman attack him in the
kitchen of his restaurant how highly
highly yours and yeah it is pretty funny
to hear him wrap up the review like this
Bill Cosby the richest man in show
business sixty seven point five million
dollars income last year reduced to
holding a coca-cola bottle next to his
face in order to get a picture made at
Columbia he ought to be ashamed of
himself yes
Cosby should really be ashamed of
himself for that Coke ad never gonna top
that
and Cisco's response is pretty much the
perfect response boy you're upset and
you know I am too it's always kind of
nice when you see them bond over a movie
they like but it's especially nice when
they bond over a movie they hate they
see something so awful they just have to
laugh at the experience like brothers in
cinematic war everybody knows that when
you do a weekly television series you
only have a little bit of time every
year to make a movie right you can make
about it's like Tom Selleck's got the
same problem you can make about one
movie a year but the plus is you got
nine months to have you and your agents
look for the right script if this is the
script they find they ought to start
doing a movie every other year and of
course you can't make fun of Cosby
without a knockin jello in there it'll
be like you know getting some of his
jello products that he sells and finding
out there's nothing in the box well I
guess you could make fun of him other
ways there's probably more appropriate
jokes now I mean inappropriate jokes
that means that don't see this movie
it's great to see them not only this
angry but also having a ton of fun being
angry
you said he's prostituted himself I say
he's I say the fact is he's disappointed
his legions of fans you have no idea how
right you both are number seven and our
next film is home-along three boy has
this franchise ever run of the gas this
review starts off as standard as you
would imagine gene rips them will be a
part mocking how unfunny and predictable
it is the story makes no sense I feel
for every family that's gonna be
suckered into singing home alone three
but to gene surprised and it all sounds
like to Roger surprised Roger likes it
now this is gonna astound you but I'm
giving the movie thumbs so it does
astound me are you okay I'm better than
you were the day that you like starship
trooper Oh then spike wait what makes
the review so funny is not only Ebert's
argument which yeah does seem kind of
bizarre this movie empowers little kids
this is the one where they finally got
it right I liked it better than the
other two but mainly cisco's reactions
he seems to mirror probably a lot of
moviegoers reactions as well it's not as
violent as the second one the kid is
charming he really is a good little
actor and the plot is smarter I mean
let's be honest even the people that
liked home alone three wouldn't think
Ebert would like home alone three the
look on Gene's face throughout the whole
thing gives the impression that this
must be a joke it has to be he seems to
be saying to himself who is this guy
I mean sure I like the babies day out
but this is home alone three it's the
same plot as the first one only more
bumps to the head a second they're all
the same plot well well you just said
that this one empowers and more than the
other one absolutely not general the
secret of the that's the city that's why
kids love these movies because they love
the fantasy that they have power
well sometimes maybe these episodes even
more fun was that the written reviews
will come out a few days before the show
would come out so when you see eber give
a film a three star rating and here's
Cisco start off bashing it right away
that's pretty enjoyable to anticipate
what the reaction was going to be and
his mouth hanging open the whole time
doesn't disappoint I thought the kid was
generic moptop and I thought that the
vocal on that kid yes come on but only
two kids it's
definitely more fun than the movie
itself overkill here that overkill not
not for you all okay number six our
first movie is named Red Dawn in this
willing get surprised to get some very
tough competition as a single philia
Thornton grocery movie a lot of times
when Siskel and Ebert watch a bad movie
they're angry at it but with Red Sonja
they almost recommended because of how
enjoyably awful it was and how much it
made them laugh this one is so enough
there are times when it's actually fun
especially when the actor struggle
through dialog that sounds like they've
already read the Mad Magazine parody of
this film listen to them they're
practically excited to talk about this
film it gave them so much joy you're mad
The Talisman will destroy you meanwhile
they're dropping dirt director right
there I've inches away from the camera
supposed to be falling on them if they
had only had plastic surgery back then
in the Middle Ages the movie would have
been over
they almost talked like kids pulling a
movie they just love sitting through so
much that they have to relive it by
shouting out their favorite parts
they're practically giddy
[Music]
my god well yeah I just love that maybe
the best moment is when Cisco wants to
describe the awkward positioning of the
Buddha in this movie but both of them
find it so funny that they came to find
the best way to say it without cracking
up well let's put it this way the Buddha
in this film that they have and here the
camp looks like the Buddha looks like we
know why you look so contented right oh
I guess you got to see the movie oh you
know I don't want to say that because I
don't see the movie the Buddha looks
like he's going to the bathroom thank
you very much a lot of times they get
pissed off at bad movies but very rare
that we see them laugh so hard and a so
bad it's good film I guess this was
their equivalent of the room sister my
brother my family that it not only did
she wipe out her family but you also
killed her sister and her brother these
two snicker like schoolboys who heard
their first dirty word is too
irresistible to pass up Red Sonja
definitely made them red in the face
coming up next to the movies our next
film
[Music]
number five
first movie is cop and a half and it's
an entertaining example of the kind of
movie formula I call the ones a movie
for example one's a cop and one's a
robber yet another disagreement but this
one Siskel loved to mock Ebert for
constantly for years and years Hebert
has admitted to being slightly more
lenient to films than Cisco and this one
even has him saying it's better than a
home alone too
this movie has the kind of chemistry
between the grown-up world and a smart
kid that I look for and missed in home
alone - not a huge accomplishment but
captain a half cisco has a lot of great
opening insults but this one might be my
personal favorite Wow where's your big
red suit and beard Santa you just gave
them a gift
Cisco then goes on to describe it as a
lame cartoon - which Ebert says that's
kind of the point and then phrases
Reynolds for playing it so realistic
Reynolds plays the cop like a real cop
instead of playing him like some kind of
a marshmallow I think if it isn't
cartoon gee I'm stunned Roger the two of
them talking about it is sadly very
short but the review doesn't stop there
in their worst of the Year episode Sisko
put this as number one unfortunately at
this time there's no video available of
that episode but IMDB does have the
episode transcribed and it's pretty damn
funny
including Siskel saying the only thing
more unnerving than this picture is my
esteemed colleague across the aisle so
why so often is the only major film
critic in America who actually
recommended cop and a half if you look
further with Ebert defending it he says
maybe you got up on the wrong side of
the bed Siskel says as did the rest of
America if you get a chance look over
the whole thing it's a pretty funny read
but even then three years later gene
still brings it up as Roger impressively
convinces him to change his vote on the
movie Broken Arrow from thumbs up two
thumbs down something neither one I've
never done before as you say this I
don't think I've ever done this on this
show in 20 years but I'm gonna twist my
thumb I'm gonna go just like this
because I told you to do it well what am
I really defending here don't even is
shocked that he actually got Siskel to
change his mind Siskel still gets in the
final insult with this
do me one favor yeah look in the camera
and say I was wrong about cop and a half
it wasn't a very good movie Burt
Reynolds I know I won't do that what
they then start reviewing cop and a half
again oh yeah I saw things in cop and a
half yeah I'm but no one else did as you
can see it's a review so funny it's
banned several episodes over several
years that's more than enough to be on
this list in event you've done a very
good thing and I've also done a good
thing too by sticking to my gun our next
film is called she's out of control and
it doesn't help that before this awful
team film they saw a really good team
film maybe you heard of it say anything
but that's only the beginning of their
hatred for this work this film exists in
a strange netherworld I think of what
Hollywood considers entertainment but is
really a sinkhole of tawdry values this
is a movie both of them agree was
actually so bad it made them question
their careers their careers of being
paid to sit and watch movies wow this
must have been pretty bad I became so
depressed I actually thought about
quitting my job as a film critic feeling
as though the movies had abandoned me
people probably think you're joking when
you said no I'm not really talking to
quitting your job but I know what you
felt it's actually so awful that made
her think about what it means to be
alive what to do with his life what
beautiful moments could be wasted
sitting here watching this train wreck
life is precious life is short and the
idiots who made this film are taking 2
hours of my life and robbing it from me
in order to give me less than nothing
they then ask them the other people who
watch this film isn't life worth more
why are you here
we have to be here because it's our jobs
but why do you continue to torture
yourselves aren't you surprised that
people stay I've always wanted to stand
up in the middle of a bad movie in a
theater and say aren't your lives worth
more for two hours and even say 7 bucks
in New York's it was 350 an hour ever
that's below the minimum wage the new
minimum wage
get out and live stand in the lobby and
talk much like Broken Arrow they
practically dismissed the film to go
back and talk about another film they
wanted to talk about the next movie we
saw the same day was say anything I'm
also about a father well also about his
daughter same kind of basic situation
but here's a trash movie and here's a
great even though they're disgusted they
still seem to be coming at it as people
who love movies
and this seems like an insult to such a
beautiful craft they're surprisingly
even close from other big-name directors
in it probably the only review of she's
out of control that has that jean-luc
Godard the great french director once
said the way to criticize a movie is to
make another movie Oscar Brockman a
Chicago film exhibitor once told me many
years ago he said there's a rule he said
if nothing has happened by the end of
the first reel nothing is going to
happen you can feel their love for
cinema in this but you can especially
feel their hatred for this movie a movie
like this is a crime because what it
does is it robs light from people by
requiring them to spend two hours having
such a terrible experience happened to
them
[Music]
number three brain candy an audacious
clever very funny news satire from the
comedy troupe known as Kids in the Hall
comedy team Kids in the Hall we made one
movie and boy did it result in a pretty
damn funny review Cisco found himself
really enjoying the film finding it
funny clever good satire I recommend
this picture is kind of a midnight show
called picture which I suspect it's
destined to become you can practically
hear either getting ready to explode and
he does exactly that when it's his turn
he's so filled with spite he barely even
reviews it he just starts shouting
name's Aldo Rod Red Bull the horrible
stupid idiotic no unfunny labored for
all right full Roger this is bad I think
well how the last one is bad as if that
would be lost on us cisco retorts with
honestly what anyone says when they just
disagree with what's funny what happened
that's kind of know what it comes down
to you won found it funny the other
didn't there's honestly not a ton to
discuss in this case but to see such a
nice and almost humble review shut down
so quickly loudly and bluntly how did
you not get a laugh out of the contrast
why did the humor was starving for a
laugh Oh Roger it almost turns into Joe
Pesci and Ray Liotta from Goodfellas the
drag stuff with robot funny how I mean
looks funny but so what if it's morning
why is it funny is there a dress funny
how I mean funny like I'm a clown am you
you Roger so pissed he says he can't
even talk about it
to which team reminds him it's kind of
their jobs we're never universe is here
we can't talk about it can't talk about
it's not funny I didn't laugh we get
paid to talk about it Friday Roger at
least admits he's happy for gene and no
big surprise gene takes that as a
compliment that's right ball I'm happy
for you no no but well let the police
about even though they wrap up the
entire episode gene still pushes it hard
brain candy Roger brain candy
dido man Dido don't ya I would check it
out I don't take you to much of it no
I'll tell you what I'm gonna see this
picture again I'm left just as hard okay
maybe I will too it's a start I guess I
don't know if Roger ever checked this
movie out again but one thing's for sure
this reaction was a lot of fun to watch
will you look at this picture again
maybe it sure I will I'd be happy to
sometime maybe in the 21st century
[Music]
number two Benji the hunted you think
this was an Edward G Robinson or maybe
today an Arnold Schwarzenegger film
might be wondering what the hell is
Benji the hunted gonna get out of these
two but surprisingly it's a lot it's
weirdly one of the most heated arguments
they ever had Cisco says he didn't like
how a few cute moments there were and
how there was too much action Benji the
hunted is two action-packed
and not cute enough Benji the hunted
exhausted me this is the first time I
wanted to tell a dog to slow down and
stop to smell the flowers it
surprisingly has a joke that almost
agreed Cisco's review well there is a
little suspense in the movie like for
example will Benji be able to protect
those cougar Cubs until they get big
enough to eat him but he jumps right
into defending it and they go pretty
heavy for Benji the friggin Hudson
junior review is the typical sort of
blase sophisticated cynical review I
would expect from an adult Jesus what's
been to your dog
oh you're wrapping yourself in the flag
of children and I'm saying I'm not
wrapping myself in the flag of choda
you're wrapping yourself in the flag of
the sophisticated film no boarding at
all no boredom boredom with venom
running how often do you hear a critic
in all honesty with pure frustrated
anger shout boredom with Bengie running
boredom boredom with venom runnin did
you grow up Roger with the boredom of
Benjy running I did I can't go back
sisq even seems to change his review
from relaying it as just not a very good
film to total garbage at the end
blackstein is a great film this all what
I recommend films for kids that are bad
but I'll tell you what whether it's good
or bad I think kids will really enjoy
a ringing endorsement it's just so funny
/ kind of odd to see two grown film
critics get so heated over Benjy the
goddamn hunted it seems like a lot of
their most heated agreements to be
around kids films but once again shows
they do take every genre very seriously
maybe even a little too seriously
I'm not wrapping myself in the flagger
chiller you're wrapping yourself in the
flag of the sophisticated film cold this
is definitely an enjoyably crazy
argument to get a few chuckles that no
boredom boredom with Ben I'll run it
before we get to number one here are
some runners-up make it lunch they both
agreed it was disgusting and disturbing
and that was the intent but he ever
found he couldn't recommend it because
it just did its job too well I guess I
have to vote thumbs down but at the same
time with a footnote that I admire what
he did and I hate it okay
strange a guardian they both cracked up
at the idea of tree gods and Eber tries
telling a joke that Siskel not
surprisingly shoots down this movie
breaks important new ground and this is
something that movie trivia X all you're
going to be funny now yes I am going to
be funny this is the first horror movie
in which a chainsaw is used against a
tree thank you for that enormous laughs
of support is not a remark jaws the
revenge they have a good time poking fun
of this film but particularly one film
flub that even Ebert had to shout out in
the middle of the screening I'm a City
no theater and I said his shirt is dry
you know this preview audience laughs
preciate it that you know I always hate
it when people talk during the movies
but I don't know that seemed to go over
pretty well yeah
curly suit Siskel literally shouts his
amazement before eeper can give his
review of it and this is a cornball
exercise and sentimental manipulation
but I don't care because it works what
the rest of the time you can hear Siskel
snickering and scoffing before it's even
his turn resulting in some good
snickering from us as well by the rude
and annoying off-screen noises that you
have been a mini and I take it that you
do not agree now let's get to it
the number one funniest Siskel and Ebert
review is
a boy played by Elijah Wood gets fed up
with his folks in that scene from North
it's kind of beautiful how much these
two hate this movie I brought up before
that they take their reviews of
children's films very seriously so it
only makes sense that they would call
this one one of the worst films they
have ever seen in their entire lives
that's a long line of movies to sit
through to pick this out so quickly but
they have no hesitation about it and
that's the set up for one of the most
thoroughly hateful movies of recent
years a movie that makes me cringe
even when I'm sitting here thinking
about it kiba's review wonderfully rips
into it pointing out both broadly and in
detail why it sucks I hated this movie
as much as any movie we've ever reviewed
in the 19 years we've been doing this
show Ypres tries to give a little
sympathy to the director Rob Reiner is
saying maybe I was just an unfortunate
misstep but school is not so kind I mean
I think you got a hold Rob riders feet
to the fire here I mean he's the guy in
charge he's saying that this is
entertainment it's deplorable the ethnic
stereotyping is appalling yes it's it's
embarrassing you feel unclean as you're
sitting there he disappeared rather
quickly and after it was gone never
really heard anyone talk about it the
only reason I still know if this film's
existence and I think really anyone does
is because of the hatred Siskel and
Ebert have for it it's junk first-class
shot and it actually made me watch this
movie to see if they were right and if
you see my review you know they're too
nice there isn't a gag that works you
couldn't write worst jokes if I told you
to write me of course everybody in the
movie was vulgar and stupid and because
the jokes weren't funny what's great as
well as both of them put it as the
number one force film of the year which
just allowed them to talk about it more
I had to think a long time to pick my
worst picture of 1994 about a 10th of a
second and believe it or not it's the
same one that you saw wild it was the
door I think it's a study it's a secret
from each other and unfortunately I
think I liked it even less than you do
if that's possible
they love digging into what an insult
this movie was in fact Ebert says
possibly his most famous line he's ever
said about any bad film
I hated this
movie hated hated hated hated hated this
movie hated it hated every simpering
stupid vacant audience and salty moment
of it this was so popular he actually
titled one of his books that these two
have had their disagreements but when
they agree on something they despise so
much they almost feel like it's their
duty to let the world know of its
stupidity you can't help a love the fact
that these two work together any subject
could be done well this is just trash
Roger okay so as you can see Siskel and
Ebert could be very professional and
they could be very unprofessional so why
did that make them great critics well
maybe because they showed just like
movies criticism can be an art as well
it can be serious it can be silly it can
be emotional it can be dry it can be so
much more than just covering the release
of a film and or just eating your
opinion of it it's not an exact science
the same way art isn't an exact science
it's about the passion in sight and yes
entertainment a critic can bring and
that's always what they did they loved
talking about movies even when they
hated them help sometimes even more when
they hated them the best thing about
them is their critiques didn't help us
form our opinions they helped us express
our opinions and how to do so in a way
that was honest and would get people to
listen because of this I'd really like
to make a push for someone anyone to try
and get clearer versions of these
reviews out there as you can tell the
quality of these are not that great and
yes I know the copyright of movie clips
can be very tough to work with
but the clips do still fall under fair
use and Siskel and Ebert really did give
us something unique and long-lasting
that we deserve to see in its clarity we
should be allowed to see the reviews the
reactions and their arguments in all
their crystal-clear passion these were
the most famous movie critics in the
world and even after their passing
there's still the most famous movie
critics in the world and it's worth
analyzing and all clarity why that is
bottom line whether it's for Julie anger
laughs or appreciation Siskel and Ebert
had a unique passion that could never be
duplicated and deserves to be respected
Leonardo DiCaprio is hunky Leonardo
DiCaprio we're talking about right now
we're talking about lost and what I'm
talking about big boy he's hunky Dan
Yugi you bet your ass I'm going out on
that clip I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to know
boredom boredom with denim running
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and not only are we doing the
carolina manga library this is a charity
we've done before they promote literacy
through graphic novels but you have a
chance to win two of the nostalgia
critic ties I've worn over the years as
part of their auction this is a
traveling library that tries to teach
literacy with graphic novels that people
can read for free and right now they're
having a fundraising auction and two of
the items are mine nostalgia critic
tides that I've worn for years and years
now the way this works is I usually wear
the same tie of ur and over until it
starts to get some wear and tear and
then we use as a stunt tie so one of
them is completely covered in blood and
the other it has a white paint splice I
was just kind of an accident but
nevertheless one of these had worn from
2014 to 2017 and the other I've worn
from 2017 to 2019 and all the splotches
of fake blood or water or whatever else
has gotten on them is still on there
because weirdly enough people usually
pay more if they're unclean I think it's
odd too but whatever will help us great
charity get more money the auction by
the time this video goes up probably
only has a few days left so definitely
click on the link and see if you can bid
on it or just go to their website and
donate something great even if it's just
other mangas or graphic novels these are
such good people that do such good work
and they're definitely worth checking
out click on the auction to possibly get
my ties or click on the great website to
see how you can help
[Music]
you